The first one of course is not a functional property because condition two is not fulfilled.
All computer programs are computer programs.
There is no computer program that is not a computer program.
Of course, this sounds a bit silly but it's actually
the only example I could think of where this condition here is violated.
A program always returns one already is a functional property.
First of all, it describes how output relates to the input
namely output doesn't care about the input and is always one
and property two is also always satisfied.
For example, there are computer programs that I could write that always return two
and property two is fulfilled for all the other three as well, so I won't even mention it anymore.
A program solves vertex cover?
Yes, definitely that describes an input-output behavior, how output relates to the input.
Is a computer a virus? I would say yes, this is a functional property.
Now, it is a bit debatable if saying it is a computer virus
already described sufficiently how the output relates to the input
but I would say that probably any definition of a computer virus that you would give me
would in some way describe what the computer virus is doing.
So, it might ignore anything that receives and overwrite your hard disc,
so put something in the memory, or it might lock your screen.
So, I would say here, the input-output behavior is variable
depending on how you define computer virus but it is always defined.
Now, the final one that is a bit of a tricky one saying that
a program only requires linear time is not a functional property
because that does not describe how the output relates to the input.
It is the property of the program but it is not a functional property
because it doesn't ask what does the program do
and what does the program do is actually this relationship here.
It only asked how fast that the program are doing that.
This is something that is a little more tricky to figure out,
but basically, any time that you ask can a program do X
that will be a functional property that you are asking for
at least in almost any of the cases.